[Music]
let's chew on that [ __ ] quit like a
[ __ ] put some francs on cement
[ __ ] barbecue
[Music]
[Music]
nope you bad [ __ ] Hojo here my
main man Lisa at getting ready for
another fun-filled evening in the Church
of what's happening now pre-show you
know we do it count the stars smoking
weed doing bong hits for the different
spirits we didn't call the anarchy guy
this week I wanted to give them a break
from it's gonna be a low night on [ __ ]
stars tonight depends who you talk to
him saying depends but we got cheaper to
chocolate tonight and mushroom chocolate
and [ __ ] god knows what else does
that's how we roll the understand Lee's
gonna eat six stars only five and a
piece of children look at I got what
[ __ ] stars one two three oh yeah cops
up is feeling good looking good Billy
right feeling good Billy ready I'm
saying just like that on a Wednesday
night [ __ ] yeah I got the star
of [ __ ] David understand me we're
going big tonight in the church
[Music]
at least favorite we got some [ __ ]
[Music]
mushroom chocolate again oh [ __ ]
things could get deep in this
[ __ ] tonight nobody knows except
you are there you dare enter this
[ __ ] house hey Dulli two down four
levels dad put the whole thing in your
mouth go go for three go for four [ __ ]
it that's a boy
that's 500 milligrams one shot drink the
water that's a boy you swallow the
[ __ ] thing they don't want to talk to
you right if they want to talk to a deaf
dude they'll [ __ ] go down to the
grocery store son dad eat that [ __ ]
stars a debt like that [ __ ] on fire
[ __ ] you gotta watch some people
he's a Jew we'll take those [ __ ]
stars up down and back he'll fix is
really
there we go of that [ __ ]
beautiful night beautiful night to say I
miss you [ __ ] I'm happy with
doing a podcast tonight we got Jimmy
Page in the bank let these [ __ ]
know how it's done
[Music]
just like a stream coming at you
[ __ ] tonight with smoke in with
the frontally smokin yoga og from
[ __ ] sunset herbal the home of
the [ __ ] Russians and Armenians I
love them to death they get me the
reefer and the hash that I need what's
up Lee you ready for some mushroom
chocolate kind this beautiful evening
it's one of those [ __ ] nights where
we have a go deeper and deeper into the
murky waters of the of the one
understand me my opening up [ __ ] I
really got weed on the table here we
still drink of the [ __ ] stars this
his [ __ ] public has broke the stars
down to [ __ ] nothing
and he's over there struggling now we're
getting ready for his first bomb that
leave me look at this beauty
[Music]
remember the old days used to do a bump
like that oh [ __ ]
BAM with a [ __ ] Christian car what
are you not so what legally saying we're
ready now length of no [ __ ] return
[Music]
it's a beautiful bond head right there
beautiful beautiful beautiful smoke
beautiful native oh that's what I'm
talking about
second if you have to abang it
good morning Cephas Coffman lungs are
coming eyeballs a pop 90 and that's when
you know you're smoking the best
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you thought I had to go home for the
door get some air in here
people gonna start faint at rain check
you're going fun for fun with the devil
tonight oh yeah everything sweats with
this week get this free for now guys you
can't get no way in fact when the guy
[ __ ] brings it down he chops it up
like [ __ ] four ways I get one dab a
little taste
you have no idea none wait for the
[ __ ] zombie apocalypse the smoke I'm
gonna blow it
they're gonna [ __ ] say Joey what
happened what happened Joe mister you
[ __ ] you know I love you so
Wednesday night if you're walking on ice
you might as well tear
[Music]
medical marijuana I don't care if it's
medical I don't care for bombing on like
in the DEA don't matter to me you know
me I'm gonna keep up the smoke that was
smoking this [ __ ]
Thompson chase you from for [ __ ]
blunt so am I gonna smoke now like this
age I don't give a [ __ ] I'll get a
skateboard and a [ __ ] maraca
and they'll be all over the Chevy
[Music]
it's not open here
[Music]
we gonna get this type at the tables we
don't watch blackish yeah good good luck
this is it people
[ __ ] that place this ain't nowhere else
we're right here on the lee side Joey
Diaz channel of death I'm [ __ ]
[Music]
tremendous
we're gonna have a raffle for the
holidays somebody comes down to the
studio we smoke dope we stab you it's a
pretty [ __ ] good deal just wanted to
believe just a little tiny want to keep
the blood alive you know saying I don't
want the blood to fizzle on them and
they don't know when Johnny Bananas
[Music]
pilot to Bombardier buy like a
bombardier you go hold anything listen
you go seek and training pays only so
much oh my god
this is serious with no delay understand
me why this you only come around this
[ __ ] planet what the heck what do you
have to sit at home and read Yelp and
the reviews was this effect of this
marijuana that's great that's a great
way [ __ ] around here no more I
understand I promised your penis will go
on beat this one a those hurricanes
terrorism doesn't matter we go big piece
of my brother lateness this is a
chocolate mint this is my variant truck
that's delicious you all want the agenda
listen I ain't got time for them we
wanna see you pass on it so what's fun
people pass out
[Music]
the favor
[Music]
salud don't call the El Nino them I've
been watching The Godfather 7 hour
episode of pieces half out with him 35
minutes here and I got to tell you
something [ __ ] him brilliant
some of the parts don't belong back in
it but it's still pretty heavy [ __ ]
duty if you haven't watched it HBO GO
got it straight and she said don't you
wanna don't you one coke a cupcake okay
please put together I'm still on like
doing one they go back and forth I put
all the [ __ ] pieces and you know they
took out what's up Lisa it has my main
man field we got dr. Seuss I ran on it
tonight
I write nice low-key they'll play a
little music my man's coming down to
talk about writing tonight the writing
process you know tell you my story how I
came to why I'm doing this special this
way she might that be just just a
conversation you're tapping maybe you
take something away from maybe you don't
know just a Frenchman's [ __ ] there's a
lot more listen
but Joey what's with the [ __ ] you
have a spark one up alright alright
alright already you know meet though you
don't they tell me two times one time
that's what they call me one time
one time our Robbie one time I [ __ ] you
one time
there's no drama there's never a second
chance
[Music]
oh [ __ ] is not like the reefer dipping
into your mind and also the [ __ ]
music go Ziggy is and it connects your
soul your heart your [ __ ] bring
togetherness like
[Music]
[ __ ] you thought I forgot about you
we passed out for a minute daddy you
mount them up thank you resuscitation we
will do another bong hit here and get
this [ __ ] party started alright
you know I love you people all my heart
dates I got tons of dates next Wednesday
at the Ice House September 8 the
slappers september 9th at the improv
Melrose September 10th at the Melrose
implement listen Austin Texas New York
City Gotham 24 to 25th you got dates of
dog I'm coming I'm coming for you I'm
saying I'm working on this [ __ ]
special shoot October 15th so I'm just
trying to put the pieces together either
in the end
are you [ __ ] I'm working on cars that
come come and prepare nice like that
bonnets relaxation don't biggest a
[ __ ] feelings hurt and it's just us
like family we will have a nice [ __ ]
holiday this year too nice Halloween
must show up [ __ ] get a hole to smile
at [ __ ]
[Music]
baby it's full your life
we're live foo-foo your life for your
life for your life here we go just when
you thought it was safe [ __ ]
alright tune into YouTube what calm /c /
Joey Diaz 10 minutes I love you bastards